bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce premier
numéro de l'année de municipales 2014 le
rendez vous politique de la rédaction
qui dorénavant vous est proposé à chaque
mardi en direct dès 18h30 et ce jusqu'à
la fin du mois de mars je recevrai dans
un instant isabelle this-saint-jean
candidate socialiste à versailles
également conseillère régionale d'île de
france lcl déjà présenté sur ce secteur
d imminente 2012 lors des législatives
et connaît donc bien son l'adversaire
direct françois de mazières pour l'ump
en seconde partie jean-louis tison
viendra en plateau il est à la tête
d'une liste divers droite à voisins le
bretonneux nous entendrons aussi l'agent
sindou faurie sans étiquette il est l'un
des sept prétendants au poste de maire à
maurepas ils siègent déjà dans
l'opposition c'est sa quatrième campagne
et puis le point aussi sur la campagne à
saint cyr qui se poursuit et rythmée par
les attaque en justice entre les
candidats première invitée isabelle
this-saint-jean bonsoir et bienvenue sur
ce plateau candidate à versailles et
c'est plutôt une surprise on attendait
plutôt marque dia ce gars m'a désigné
premier des socialistes par la section
locale il y a quelques semaines on a
d'ailleurs pu lire dans la presse locale
parachutage en règle au ps votre
réaction pour commencer je pense que
c'est une histoire qu'il faut très
rapidement mettre derrière nous moi je
suis là pour faire une campagne aussi
dynamique que possible avec tout le
monde en embarquant tout le monde on est
dans une situation
où le
il ya vraiment une nécessité de donner
un nouveau souffle à versailles je crois
que versailles est une ville absolument
extraordinaires en termes de potentiel
en terme enfin c'est quand même une
ville mondialement connue avec un parti
un patrimoine architectural
mondialement connu une destination
touristique incroyable et en même temps
versailles a un côté complètement en 2
100 de son potentiel avec des vrais
fragilité ans on a vu récemment
versailles classé en troisième position
en dernier de liste du classement de sa
capacité à traiter des problèmes de
discrimination donc on voit qu'il ya des
inégalités dans versailles il ya un
potentiel qui est pas révélée
une capacité à faire avec versailles des
choses qui sont à fait aujourd'hui ils
ont les crocs de votre programme mais
juste votre arrivée sur l'aja comment
s'est décidée votre arrivée sur cette
ville je me disais tout à l'heure vous
connaissez le secteur vous étiez déjà
candidate aux législatives
vous étiez venus d'ailleurs à cette
occasion sur le plateau mais il
n'empêche arrivé à ce moment-là de la
campagne on est à trois mois des
élections du premier tour annoncez votre
candidature à trois mois ce sera pas de
trop court pour aussi vous faire
connaître parce que malgré tout on ne
vous a pas vu tant que ça depuis les
législatives à versailles mais c'est
vrai qu'on m'a pas vu tant que ça parce
que j'ai un mandat à la région qui un
mandat extrêmement lourd je m'occupe de
tout la recherche et de l'enseignement
supérieur de la région ile de france ce
qui représente 40 % du potentiel
scientifique français avec ses
universités des grandes écoles comptent
par dizaines et donc du coup c'est vrai
que j'ai été pas au quotidien sur le
terrain et sur versailles et pourquoi
cette candidature alors juste alors ce
que parce que très occupé à l'arrêt oui
parce que c'est arrivé parce que en fait
on m'a demandé de le faire et que j'ai
trouvé que c'était un très beau
challenge
et qu' il y avait vraiment quelque chose
à faire et donc j'ai accepté cette
proposition qui m'a été fait mais ça n'a
pas été spontanément quelque chose sur
lequel moi je suis parti
je mets en revanche maintenant que j'ai
pris ma décision
maintenant que j'y suis né j'y vais avec
toute la détermination qui est la mienne
et parler de challenge et justement vous
étiez face à françois de mazières aux
législatives il l'avait emporté sur la
circonscription avec près de 57% et si
on regarde le score juste sur la ville
de versailles sa victoire c'était 72%
comment vous allez inverser cette
tendance comment vous allez refaire son
retard même si ce n'est pas le même
scrutin de mai ce sont les mêmes
personnels ce sont les mêmes personnes
ceci étant c'est pas du tout le même
scrutin
c'est
effectivement c'est pas pour ça que
quand on parle de parachutage c'est
enfin je veux dire un parachutage c'est
quand on envoie des gens de stature
nationale sur des terrains qui sont des
terrains gagnés à qu'ils avancent donc
là c'est pas du tout mon cas c'est pas
du tout mon cas moi je suis sûr sur un
endroit où a priori c'est vrai que ça va
être très difficile on est dans une
conjoncture nationale compliqué je suis
face à maire sortant et
on est dans une dans un moment aussi je
crois qu'il ya un moment sur versailles
très particulier avec la première
attaque du mariage pour tous donc ça va
être difficile c'est évident d'aller
faire la preuve qu'elles s'embrasent
assez bien alors je passe je
n'aurais pas d'astuce
mais en revanche beaucoup de
détermination de franchise d'ouvrir de
montrer tout le dynamisme possible pour
cette ville je crois que versailles ne
se réduit pas à la caricature qui est
donnée de versailles qui a beaucoup de
gens à versailles qui habite à
versailles et qui ont envie que leur
ville soit une ville qui soit beaucoup
plus des derniers beaucoup plus ouverte
beaucoup moins repliée sur elle même
beaucoup plus ouverte aux jeunes et
c'est ça que je vais et ses fastes c'est
de ça dont je vais essayer de les
convaincre et un petit peu sur la
division malgré tout la droite puisqu'il
y aura plusieurs listes à droite il ya
une seule liste soutenue par l'ump mais
il y aura une liste de la manif pour
toucher notamment il ya une liste du
front national du rassemblement bleu
marine aussi qui se présente est ce que
ça peut vous permettre de gagner des
points
ouais et alors je n'aime pas trop jouer
sur la division d'adversaires c'est pas
un truc que j'aime faire
enfin je dis ça comme si j'étais une
vieille routière de la politique ce qui
n'est vraiment pas le cas souvenez de ma
trajectoire société civile issus l'issue
de la société civile non mais c'est
prévu dans des salles de l'université
alors sur le bassin de 50 ans et 50 ans
il ya une universitaire
si vous le souhaitez donc je n'étais pas
enfin je ne suis pas partisane de jouer
sur les failles de l'adversaire surtout
quand il s'agit du front national moi je
ne joue pas avec ça je suis très
préoccupé de la situation
de la démocratie en ce moment de manière
globale je suis très inquiète de ce qui
se passe sur versailles avec cette
focalisation sur le dossier du mariage
pour tous la loi est passée je pense
qu'il est vraiment temps et je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de nos concitoyens à
versailles qui ont envie que on passe à
autre chose qu'à tous les beaucoup de
monde lors il avait manifesté sur la fin
de l'année qui concernait les future loi
sur la famille oui il y avait beaucoup
de monde mais en même temps si on
rapporte ça à l'ensemble de la
population de versailles je suis pas sûr
que l'ensemble des versaillais et envie
que l'on continue à travailler cette
question là à être là dessus en tous les
cas je pense que ça serait une erreur
vraiment ça serait une erreur que
versailles mérite beaucoup mieux que ça
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
aujourd'hui qui sont à traiter que nous
avons une génération qui y est dans une
situation extrêmement compliquée
notamment en termes d'emploi qu' il ya
une nouveau modèle de développement a
relancé avec la prise en compte de
considérations écologiques qui doivent
être au premier prendre nos
préoccupations et que la question du
mariage pour tous je crois qu'il faut un
moment la met de côté pour passer à
autre chose
et pour traiter
deux problèmes qui sont des problèmes
déterminants pour notre avenir votre
priorité l'avenir justement inscrire la
ville de versailles dans une dynamique
de l'île de france puisque vous êtes
conseil régional on imagine bien et puis
aussi du territoire de saclay alors ça
passe par quelle mesure qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire justement pour cette ville de
versailles pour la lancer dans l'île de
france est lancée sur le territoire de
saclay alors sur le territoire de saclay
ça fait longtemps que alors en tant que
vice-présidente là je travaillais en ce
sens j'ai toujours été content très très
intimement convaincu que saclay le
projet de saclay ne pouvait pas se
réduire à simplement le plateau non et
j'ai toujours dit saclay c'est bien plus
que ça saclay c'est saclay et son
environnement et donc ça ne peut pas se
faire sans
l'université de 50 ans de la même
manière que ça peut pas se faire sans
evry donc il ya vraiment nécessité d'un
périmètre plus large et on voit bien que
l'université de versailles saint quentin
que la communauté de versailles grand
parc et bien tout ça doit faire en sorte
que ça s'inscrive dans le projet de
saclay et que ça permette de deux
d'inscrire versailles dans le périmètre
large de saclay ça c'est une première
chose et puis ensuite il ya tout là
premier match du grand paris et des
transports ou là on aura une inscription
directe de versailles je crois que c'est
vraiment on est dans un moment où c'est
une opportunité formidable pour cette
ville et pour tous ses habitants et pour
tous les habitants de l'île de france ou
si un versailles a une responsabilité
par un parent au regard de l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens
de retrouver un nouveau souffle de
retrouver une dynamique économique
et de deux de sortir de son de son
espèce de rage je veux pas avoir des
mots blessants mais de deux voilà de
repli un peu sur soi à l'intérieur de
soi même je crois que il ya vraiment
besoin d'un nouveau souffle pour
versailles chez sabz marseille sa main
ce
nouveau souffle va pas être coupés
courts avec les difficultés de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
justement est-ce que c'est un handicap
pour l'avenir de versailles si cette
université n'arrivent pas à attirer
justement de nouveaux partenaires
financiers a du coup fait revenir aussi
d'autres étudiants et à se développer on
le sait l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines un gros déficit on
en a parlé sur cette antenne notamment
avec le président alors là je voudrais
vraiment avoir une pas leurs paroles
rassurantes parce qu'il ya eu des propos
qui ont été
extrêmement anxiogène pour les chats
mignons et pour pour les jeunes qui
suivent des études ça n'est pas
envisageable une seconde que cette
université ferme ça ne veut dire ça
n'est pas possible
il ya pu y avoir par exemple avec
l'antenne de poitiers
des menaces de décision de fermeture
d'une antenne mais ça n'est pas une
université l'université c'est une
institution c'est à la fois un lieu et
en même temps c'est une institution on
n'a jamais vu la fermeture d'une
université donc là je crois qu'il faut
rassurer les étudiants rassurer les
familles l'université de versailles
saint quentin ne fermera pas et moi en
tant vice présidente de région je me
serais mis un certain nombre de
dispositifs en marche qui font que voilà
on a on va dégager un million pour
l'université en plus de tous les
financements que régulièrement on donne
à l'université on dégage un million pour
la sortir de cette situation de déficit
il ya un certain nombre de mesures qui
doivent être prises qui font que
l'université va rentrer dans les clous
elle a renégocié son ppp et là c'est là
où je trouve quand même que
les élus de l'opposition de l'ump sont
quand même du secteur sont quand même
assez étonnant dire que la situation de
l'université elle résulte quand même en
très grande part d'une situation
financière globale mais aussi et surtout
de décisions qui ont été prises par
valérie pécresse lorsqu'elle était en
responsabilité et qu'elle incitait les
universités à aller vers les ppp c'est
un peu technique sur les électeurs
belges et puis on va pas refaire le
débat mais n'est pas lent que moi je
résistais n'est que la région rifflet
range l'émotion thaler vous étiez
présidente du collectif sauvons la
recherche qui est 17 mai cp c'est
tellement bon tant que vice présidente
de région que j'ai résisté que j'ai
refusé d'aller dans les ppp en disant
c'est un mode de 10 heures un dispositif
extrêmement dangereux pour les
universités expression chère à
versailles vous n'en ferais pas ça c'est
sûr ce qui me permet de revenir à cette
campagne ce que pour conclure sur cette
ville de versailles comment va se passer
la suite de votre campagne sur le
terrain est ce que la liste aujourd'hui
et complète est ce que l'ensemble des
formations de gauche vous ont fait
confiance en tant que tête de liste
alors c'est s'est pour l'instant ça
n'est pas je ne peux pas vous dire qu'il
ya une liste complète et qu'on a négocié
avec tous les partenaires mais c'est
très sincèrement très bonne voie la
négociation avec les partenaires moi je
souhaite arriver vraiment en tendant la
main
aux partenaires de gauche
et je ne doute pas du fait que l'on soit
rejoint très largement c'est à dire
l'ensemble le but c'est de fédérer
l'ensemble de la gauche d'arriver unis
de passer au delà des querelles qui ont
fait que voilà on est venu me demander
de mener cette campagne ce que je fais
avec beaucoup de détermination
donc je reprends tout ça une présence
sur les terrains très rapidement avec
vos paiements le temps j'ai juste
dernier excusez moi vous allez me
répondre par oui ou par non là à l'issue
de la campagne si vous n'êtes pas élu et
que vous siégez dans l'opposition vous
allez rester durablement sur versailles
oui oui ça je quand je prends un
engagement je prends un engagement
lardin donc la réponse est oui et en
revanche si je suis élu maire de
versailles je ne cumulerait pas les
mandats et donc tant pis j'abandonnerai
ce mandat que j'adore les ennemis de
vice-président de la région mais je sais
merci à l'elysée avant d'être plateau je
rappelle sur versailles ans il ya aussi
une liste soutenue par l'ump et celle du
maire sortant françois de mazières
françois simeoni pour le rassemblement
bleu marine le front national il y aura
aussi vraisemblablement un candidat issu
du mouvement de la manif pour tous
municipales 2014 qui se poursuit et dans
quelques minutes jean louis tison
candidats à voisins le bretonneux
à maurepas sept candidats se disputent
le poste de maire de nouveaux noms sont
entrés officiellement dans la course fin
décembre nagy de bâches pour debout la
république mais également jean sindou
faurie à sans étiquette lui siège déjà
dans l'opposition il entend mener sa
campagne notamment sur la question de
l'intercommunalité
et simplement fait bon temps
actuellement non pas bien d'être attaché
comme quand on épluche est le printemps
arabe et je suis donc commencer
découpage cantonal va de la fin et
l'impact et dans l'autre sens même pas
je fais un beau diable exposé alors
naissant qui n'a rien contre les dents
c'est bien les
arrêts mais ce n'est pas très
raisonnable je vois pas où la pertinence
de ces faits supplémentaires avec
l'intercommunalité on peut deviner la 38
il a distancé tous ses amendements
déposés michel n'y a pas de cohérence
dans le fonctionnement et je ne vois pas
ce que c'est très important de
structures intéressantes pour délit de
maurepas et je pense qu'avec
oculaire vraiment à 2 juillet va c'est
un de choses à part communalité et de
leucate il faut absolument revoir ses
têtes marché est l'occasion de proposer
un renouveau des équipes médicales
puisque pour certains cette rentrée 24
ans qui sont aux commandes et je pense
qu'il ya un moment où il faut changer
les choses donc là on a l'occasion de
présenter une option différente avec des
gens disent à la fois expérimenté
magique à la nadal espère que j'étais à
nice manger et et produits naturels et
tétouan donc il faut des réponses et
jour nouveau pourquoi devrait-on dire
dans le candidat au temps des
séries dire que les enfants investissent
est donc remarquable ses premiers points
de l'année c'est ça qui a pêché pendant
les années précédentes
là il faut absolument
vraiment facile d'aller vraiment pouvoir
aux gens et des personnes d'autres
personnes que celles sion était aux
commandes pendant longtemps vous avez
vous soutient que les autres candidats
les autres listes pour un éventuel
rapprochement les pêcheurs du sud
heureusement on peut discuter qu'on peut
parler est important de hauteur et bien
leur fasse parler
la campagne à saint cyr l'école qui se
poursuit à coup de procès le maire
sortant bernard de bain ump a décidé
d'attaquer son opposant de gauche
danielle guerre sont en cause un sondage
commandé par la ville sur les intentions
de vote des citoyens et la réaction du
candidat soutenu par le parti socialiste
pour bernardin daniel garçon a prétendu
que ces dépenses avaient un caractère
électoral avérés et qu'elle pouvait être
qualifiée de détournement de fonds
publics il dépose donc une plainte pour
diffamation publique de son côté son
ancienne adjointe donc au maire sortant
qui se présentent aussi contre lui en
mars prochain gaitan desjardins annonce
elle aussi son intention de déposer une
plainte si le maire ne rembourse pas la
totalité du sondage serait obligé de
déposer plainte contre lui afin de me
protéger c'est ce qu'elle exprime bien
communiqué la candidate divers droite
qui estime que ce choix de ne payer
qu'une partie de la somme totale de ce
sondage on revient à dire que les autres
candidats doivent aussi assumer sur
leurs fonds de campagne
la suite de ce numéro 2 municipales 2014
avec jean-louis tison bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes candidats pour ces élections
sur voisin candidat divers droite sur
voisins le bretonneux c'est une
constante à chacune de ces élections
locales dans cette ville cette division
de la droite je rappelle que le maire
sortant alexis d'y était déjà opposé à
son ancienne première adjointe alexandra
rosetti et vous même vous étiez dans
l'équipe majoritaire lors d'un mandat
qui s'est terminé en 2008 pourquoi déjà
ce choix de revenir en politique après
avoir fait une parenthèse entre 2008 et
2014 et goûter c'est pas vraiment une
parenthèse bois ce qui me concerne le
plus directement c'est d'abord notre
opposition de gauche notre opposition de
gauche je n'oublie jamais que j'en
arrache réuni toute la gauche à
voisins-le-bretonneux du ps au front de
gauche au parti communiste et il a
réalisé 49 % en 2000 à 40 9 % en 2001
face à la liste de lixiviat en 2008 il à
alexis piette a été élu avec moins de
40% des voix et jean h c'est arrivé
trois ou quatre pour cent derrière donc
en fait notre premier adversaire
essentiel c'est la liste de gauche de la
liste conduite par jean h 23 listes à
droite alors 3,3 l'arize le nombre de
voix potentiellement pour les
sympathisants de droite alors 3 3 listes
à droite pour le moment alexis millette
présente présente sa liste évidemment
pour ma part moi si vous voulez j'ai une
crédibilité sur les thèmes qui sont les
plus importants les thèmes des finances
les thèmes de l'urbanisme et je compte
bien présenter mes thèmes et gagner sur
ces thèmes on va parler de ces thèmes
juste pour revenir sur ce que vous venez
de dire vous venez dire pour l'instant
il y a trois listes à droite ça veut
dire que on pourrait imaginer que vous
vous rapprochez d'une autre liste alors
imagine mal celle du maire sortant vu
les relations que vous entretenez avec
lui mais celle d'alexandre arrosé talent
alors alexandrins rosetti elle est
courageuse elle a des convictions elle a
payé ses convictions elle a été isolée
moi je sais ce que c'est aussi que
d'être isolé en politique
on se retrouve sur beaucoup de sujets
par exemple elle n'a pas voté pour le
vélodrome moi je n'aurais pas voté pour
le vélodrome si j'avais été au conseil
communautaire récemment donc oui
effectivement donc ce n'est également
avec jules lavie je l'invite à ce que
nos listes se réunissent absolue entre
soumet ce que la discussion est déjà
engagée parce que c'est un souhait que
vous exprimez ça sera ça avance
les discussions avancent éventuellement
il y aurait donc une liste on
sollicitera aussi alexandra rosetti pour
entendre son conditions sur cette
question de taken on va revenir sur vos
thèmes de campagne en tout cas vous
parliez également des reproches à la
gestion actuelle de la ville triplement
au moins de l'endettement de la commune
depuis votre départ des finances en 2007
c'est ce que vous dites alors il ya une
pression insupportable des impôts
actuellement sur voisins et je compte y
mettre fin en fixant des priorités la
pression insupportable des impôts c'est
tous les jours pour ma part
factuellement 27 % d'augmentation des
impôts
cette année il ya eu des modifications
sur le taux d'abattement
l'augmentation est très forte et porte
encore plus sur les petits logements que
sur les grands logements dont on parle
pour les petits logements de 8 10 15 %
pour la taxe d'habitation
c'est insupportable on est venu me voir
on est venu me voir on me dit monsieur
disant je ne vais plus pouvoir rester à
voisins je ne vais plus pouvoir rester à
voisin parce que les impôts augmentent
trop fort moi je vais y mettre fin à
cette augmentation des impôts et julie
augmentation des impôts des dépenses des
recettes en tout cas ça veut dire qu'il
est aussi augmentation des dépenses vous
aller couper certains projets pour
limiter la hausse des impôts alors je
vais d'abord mettre fin à l'augmentation
des impôts parce que les fixes les
recettes sont fixés par les taux actuels
et moi je connais les lignes budgétaires
du budget j'ai été maire adjoint aux
finances pendant plus de sept ans je
connais chaque ligne budgétaire je sais
où est ce qu'on peut faire des économies
je sais où fixer les priorités les
priorités il ya des vrais sanctuaire les
vrais sanctuaire à voisins-le-bretonneux
ce sont les écoles nous avons six
groupes scolaires ouverts nous
maintiendrons les six groupes scolaires
ouverts nous maintiendrons et crèches
ouvertes c'est essentiel notre
territoire est trop répartie coupées par
des routes départementales
je maintiendrai également et je
renforcerai les les budgets les aides
aux associations parce qu'une
association c'est d'abord le résultat
d'une initiative privée et je compte
véritablement
renforcer l'aide aux subventions parce
qu'elle apporte beaucoup à la ville de
voisins en ce qui concerne les économies
bien sûr qu'il ya des économies à
trouver comme partout comme dans un
budget comme dans un budget de famille
on fera des économies je vais en citer
un quelques exemples des pistes
d'économies le maire ou écoutez j'ai ma
voiture j'ai pas besoin d'une voiture de
la commune pour aller au travail pour
allez partir en vacances je roulerai
avec mon propre vie ni sur les budgets
le chrono vol le protocole on n'a pas
besoin d'un protocole énorme nous sommes
une ville ça me suffit de nous sommes
une ville de 12000 habitants qui réduit
son nombre d'habitants n'a pas besoin de
grossesse et s'affaisser fier
certainement pas ça ne suffira pas il
faut regarder véritablement les
priorités les projets des projets qui
sont mal adaptés à la ville je donne un
exemple la croix la croix du mois on a
aménagé pour des centaines de milliers
d'euros des projets à la croix du bois
un théâtre de plein air on a un deuxième
projet qui ait démarré pour remettre
encore de l'argent au pot sur des
projets comme ça je mettrai fin à des
projets comme ça parce que le théâtre
par exemple au théâtre naturel en plein
air à la croix du bois en 2012 le jour
de la fête des mères il faisait grand
soleil il y avait un théâtre il y avait
huit spectateurs 8 spectateurs c'est un
des spectateurs qui me l'a dit donc il
ya des projets qui sont inadaptées vous
dis ceci tout et de l'arrière 0-2 et lui
aussi qui servent à servir
essentiellement les projets personnels
du maire vous n'adoptez pas reprendre
aussi au niveau du pq ce plan ce plan
d'habitation ce plan d'urbanisme pardon
alors vous savez l'urbanisme lévy sinois
l'ebit sinois ils sont attachés à
l'identité de voisins à la fois mi-rural
me urbaine et l'urbanisme il doit
refléter cette
ce visage et qu'est-ce qui ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui on voit un urbanisme
extrêmement dense en particulier au
centre ville qui est inacceptable qui
rend la cohabitation
inacceptable impossible entre les
maisons qui existent et les bars qui
nous qui sont verticales et qui monte
qui dévisagent vous en prenez aussi aux
logements sociaux ce quota de 25 % pour
vous il est inatteignable il faut
revenir sur ces logements que dans ce
jeu je termine sur l'urbanisme s'est
brièvement après alors on ne peut pas
actuellement continuer avec des densités
qui nous sont proposées comme cela
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a effectivement
une densité qui nous est proposé comme
celle là c'est à cause de la loi sru la
loi sru qui a besoin d'être aménagé pour
prendre en compte les spécificités de la
ville nouvelle la loi sru alors que et
elle est arrivée en
1998 voisin a été aménagé à 90% partie
de la ville nouvelle voisin était un
quartier résidentiel avec sa vocation de
quartiers résidentiels on nous a dit en
1998 et bien maintenant il vous faut 20
% de logements sociaux et cette question
là est au coeur du tout le débat sur le
plus sur l'urbanisme à voisin de ça veut
dire stop au logement social hors bel20
suzanne bien sûr que non bien sûr que
non il nous faut des logements il nous
faut des logements sociaux mais je pense
que la loi sru devra être aménagé elle a
été aménagée dernièrement on est passé
de 20 à 25% il est nécessaire que la loi
sru soit aménagé pour le cas particulier
sans temps que des villes est ce que
vous pouvez faire parce qu'en voulant et
bien et bien moi en tant que maire en
tant que maire de la ville de la plus
grande ville d'une grande
circonscription des yvelines j'aurais du
poids auprès des élus je mobiliserai les
députés je mobiliserai les conseillers
généraux conseillers régionaux pour que
nous aménageons cette loi sru parce que
c'est elle qui est le poison de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui conditionne
toujours les finances sont les deux
priorités même s'il ya d'autres sur le
programme on est on est pris par le
temps on aura l'occasion de développer
ça lors d'une prochaine
heureusement j'ai d'autres on aura
l'occasion de venir vous voir pour
poursuivre cette campagne bien sûr tous
les candidats s'expriment sur cette
antenne vous le savez municipales 2014
l'émission c'est chaque mardi 18h30 en
direct sur télé fils et puis très
prochainement dès le mois de février il
y aura également des débats avec
l'ensemble des candidats vous serez bien
évidemment conviés gens utilisant merci
d'être venu sur ce château candidats sur
voisins-le-bretonneux mardi prochain
18h30 vous avez rendez vous avec
catherine viola tôt pour le nouveau
numéro de municipal